[Musik]
es ist eine traurige Geschichte die
damals geschehen ist am 20 Juli 1944
aber die Bundeswehr sagt das was
Staufenberg und seine Mitstreiter
versucht haben den Tyrannen zu töten und
damit das Morden das sinnlose sterben in
Europa zu beenden und Deutschland wieder
zurück in die Völkergemeinschaft zu
führen war nicht umsonst denn sozusagen
sein Gedächtnis sein Geist lebt weiter
und damit herzlich willkommen phöniix V
Ort meldet sich heute Abend live aus dem
Verteidigungsministerium in Berlin heute
an diesem 20 Juli 2012 findet hier eine
öffentliches Gelöbnis statt 400 Rekruten
werden gleich ihr Gelöbnis ablegen und
wir werden das Ganze live übertragen der
Bundeswehr ist es wichtig das Ansehen
von Staufenberg zu pflegen und will
damit Hinweise geben für die Soldaten
wie sie ihre whrpflicht wie sie ihren
Dienst für das Vaterland in Zukunft dann
ablegen werden mit welchem Bewusstsein
Sie diesen Dienst leisten werden wir
sind sozusagen im Vorlauf des
Gelöbnisses die Rekruten sind schon
eingetroffen und oberstleutwand Uwe
ziesag ist bei uns der wird das Ganze
freundlicherweise fachkundig für uns
kommentieren wir haben noch einen ganz
kleinen Moment Zeit bevor es hier
richtig losgeht das offizielle Programm
startet ich habe es gesagt es findet ja
alles statt an diesem 20 Juli 44 der ja
ein dramatischer ein schwieriger Tag war
ähm im Erinnern an Staufenberg und seine
Mitstreiter warum macht die Bundeswehr
das warum sollen die jungen Rekruten die
heute hier ihr Gelöbnis ablegen das im
Bewusstsein an Staufenberg tun also im
Traditionsanlass der Bundeswehr ist
festgelegt dass die Traditionslinie der
Bundeswehr auf drei Bereichen beruht das
sind einmal die Reformer von 1813 also
Gneisenau Scharnhorst und und vom Stein
dann der Widerstand gegen Adolf Hitler
und sein staatstoristisches Regime also
Staufenberg und dann die Geschichte der
Bundeswehr selber das sind also die drei
großen Traditionslinie die die
Bundeswehr hat das ist ein toller Tag
für diese jungen Leute ein spannender
Tag bevor wir eingehen auf das Prozedere
das hier gleich stattfinden wird noch
einen Satz zu dem was es hier ja an
Diskussionen heute gegeben hat vor allem
hier in der Hauptstadt über den Ort des
Geschehens wir sind ja hier im
Bendlerblock das gehört zum Gelände des
teiligungsministeriums hier wurde damals
auch Staufenberg
erschossen und in den letzten drei
Jahren fand dieses öffentliche Gelöbnis
am 20 Juli immer auf dem Platz vor dem
Reichstag statt diesmal aber nicht warum
ist das so also wir hatten ja hier
vorher schon Gelöbnisse gehabt auf
diesem Platz es waren hochrangige Gäste
hier ich erinnere nur daran dass der
Vorsitzende des Zentralrates der Julen
in Deutschland Paul Spiegel damals hier
eine Rede gehalten hat dass der
polnische Staatspräsident hier zu Gast
gewesen ist und sich sehr in einer sehr
emotionalen positiven Rede an die
Soldaten gewandt hat und der
Verteidigungsminister und der
Bundestagspräsident haben sich eben
darauf geeinigt dass es einmal hier
stattfinden soll vorm wendlerblock und
einmal vor dem Reichstagsgebäude und
sind eigentlich beides würdige Orte
Reichstagsgebäude natürlich bekannter
weil dort der Sitz des deutschen
Parlamentes ist aber auch der
Bendlerblock sie sprachen es gerade eben
an Gedenkstelle deutscher Widerstand und
auch das Ehrenmal der Bundeswehr es hier
beheimatet für die gefallenen Soldaten
das ist ja in den letzten Jahren hier
eingerichtet worden mehr als 40 deutsche
Soldaten sind ja in Afghanistan gefallen
und auch an diese Menschen wird an
diesem Ort erinnert das wollen wir nicht
vergessen zu erwähnen nun haben die
Rekruten ja Aufstellung genommen welche
Waffengattung sehen wir jetzt wir sehen
jetzt die Rekruten der Luftwaffe wir
müssen also heute sagen wir haben heute
auch ein norwurm wieder dabei wir haben
eigentlich immer ein norwurm dabei heute
sind Rekruten aus allen fünf
Organisationsbereichen bzw
teilstreiträften hier vertreten also
hier Luftwaffe Marine Sanität und
Streitkräfte
[Musik]
Basis gute Rekruten sind einmarschiert
haben jetzt Aufstellung genommen was
wird danach geschehen jetzt wird leicht
dieinformation einmarschieren die wie
Lautsprecher gerade sagt aus dem der
Bundeswehr und eben aus einer Formation
des Bataillons in Stärke von ca 150
Soldaten werden hier einmarschieren und
dann hier dann kann es quasi losgehen
mit dem Gelöbnis das ganze wird
natürlich auch mit Musik untermalt
welche Musik wird gewählt für diesen
Zweck da gibt's immer unterschiedliche
kommt drauf an wer spielt heute spielt
das musikchor aus aus Bonn Bonn Siegburg
und die wählen immer etwas konzertantere
Musik aber wenn die Musikstücke nachher
kommen kann ich ja noch eineige Dinge
dazu anmerken genau Prominenz wird
gerade hier hier genannt natürlich der
Verteidigungsminister ist da Thomas
demesier der Generalinspekteur der
Bundeswehr vielleicht Kannen noch mal
kurz erläutern wie das Verhältnis
zwischen den beiden ist also der
Verteidigungsminister ist zwar sozusagen
der politische Dienst und wie sieht die
arbeitsilung mit Herrn wier aus die ist
eigentlich ganz einfach der
Verteidigungsminister ist der
Oberbefehlshaber der Bundeswehr in
Friedenszeiten so einfach ist das und
Herr general wier ist der oberste Soldat
der Bundeswehr also der höchste Soldat
der Bundeswehr so die gastgebende Stadt
ist quasi auch vertreten Klaus Hit die
regierende Bürgermeister Peter Ramsauer
der Verkehrsminister ist auch hier und
wohnt dem Gelöbnis bei das ist kein Eid
der gleich abgelegt wird sondern es ist
ein Gelöbnis das ist eine eine andere
Form von Treueschwur den die Soldaten
hier gleich ablegen würden wie lautet er
ich gelobe der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland treu zu dienen und das Recht
und die Freiheit des deutschen Volkes
tapfer zu verte
kann auch geleistet werden mit der
Formel wird hier wahrscheinlich gemacht
so war mir Gott
helfe jetzt sind die Soldaten seit 1
Juli im Dienst der Bundeswehr das heißt
sie sind jetzt schon seit rund 3 Wochen
Soldaten oder wird man jetzt erst zum
Soldat wenn man gleich das Gelöbnis
abgelegt hat nein die sind natürlich
schon seit 1 Juli bei uns bei der
Bundeswehr aber wenn ich mich noch an
meine Zeit erinnere die liegt ja nun
auch schon fast 35 Jahre zurück da muss
man sich erst einge das sind andere
Lebensumstände hier da möglicherweise
auch ein anderer Ort wo man seinen
Dienst tut hier und da braucht man schon
bisschen Gewöhnung um sich hier
einzugewöhnen ich kann mir vorstellen
dass eigentlich auch alle ein bisschen
aufgeregt sein werden denn die kommen ja
aus zehn verschiedenen Standorten hier
in Deutschland nach Berlin sind sie hier
gekommen auch eine Premiere und da ist
ja schon was Besonderes wenn man hier
sein Gelöbnis leistet das ist ja jetzt
eine freiwilligen Armee das ist jetzt
keine Armee der Wehrpflichtigen mehr ist
es schon ein großer Unterschied zu
früher man mer schon man kann schon
merken die Umgangsformen sind einfach
ein bisschen anders geworden hier
man merkt auch daran
dass das vor dass man man so sieht
nehmen wir mal die die Zahlen die wir
haben 25% entschließen sich hier quasi
vorzeitig Durchschnitt ihren ihren
freiwilligleisteten werdienst
abzubrechen aus privaten Gründen
aus persönlichen Gründen hier aus
beruflichen Grund weil man einen anderen
Job beispielsweise gefunden hat das war
vorher so in dieser Zeit nicht möglich
gewesen hier man traut sich kaum was zu
sagen es ist ganz still auf dem Platz
wir sind quasi die einzigen die im
Moment hier sprechen ist es bewusst so
gewählte Inszenierung oder gehört es
einfach zum Protokoll das gehört einfach
zu der fallen Zeremonie dazu dass nicht
ich sag mal gesprochen wird hier dass
nicht irgendemand einer zwischen redet
hier sondern dass man sich auf die
Veranstaltung konzentriert und die
Veranstaltung soll ja auch eine gewisse
Würde repräsentieren aber wir sind weit
genug weg wir können reden wir stören
die Veranstaltung auch nicht dort Marine
dort ganz genau die Marinesoldaten und
Soldatin aus
Bremerhafen von der Marine
operationsschule jetzt sehen wir die
Sanitäter die kommen aus dem hohen
Norden Deutschlands aus
seed eine wichtige Rolle kann ich mir
vorpellen spielen die Sanitäter auch
angesichts der Situation in Afghanistan
die sanitätstruppe ist natürlich sehr
gefordert ja bei allen Einsätzen und
also auch
personellstark im Einsatz hier
entsprechend ver
neben den 400 Rekruten die gleich das
Gelöbnis ablegen werden sind auch
Familienangehörige geladen insgesamt
sind hier 2000 Gäste im Innenhof des
Verteidigungsministeriums haben sich ja
versammelt bisher hat Gott lobt des
Wetter mitgespielt das war ja in den
letzten Tagen nicht so und das war auch
in den letzten Jahren nicht unbedingt so
ich habe mir sagen lassen im letztes
Jahr letztes Jahr war es so warm dann
sind da sind einige der Rekruten der
neurekruten umgegibt ja die Witterung
ist natürlich ideal nicht man könnte
jetzt auch Fußball Spielen nicht also so
20° nicht leichter Wind also wunderbar
also auch für das Gelöbnis hier und wir
hatten hier schon
und die unterschiedlichsten
witterungsbedingung Strömer Regen Hitze
sass wir auch mal ein Gelöbnis hatten wo
die Rekruten nur im kurzen Hemd
angetreten
sind
die Musik setzt ein was genau geschieht
jetzt jetzt marschiert die ihrination
ein und die Truppenfahne wir werden das
gleich im Bild sehen können
Ehrenformation heißt was sind das für
Soldaten das sind Soldaten des
Wachbataillons hier aus Berlin eine
Ehrenkompanie
ungefähr 100 Soldaten die hier anehen
mit der Truppenfahne und an der Spitze
das musikchor der Bundeswehr aus
[Musik]
Bond
nun geht's an den Rekruten vorbei das
kann man schön sehen aber da gibt es
auch für die neurekruten kein Vertun die
dürfen keine Miene verziehen die müssen
stramm stehen das haben sie schon den
ersten di Wochen zuerst lernen müssen
oder das war ich der Schwerpunkt der
Ausbildung weil der 20 Juli liegt ja
ziemlich nah am Monatsbeginn dran dass
man darauf eben den Schwerpunkt liegt
auf den Formaldienst und die haben
natürlich hier auch einen dabei den
Protokoll Feldwebel vom Wachbataillon
der vorher die ne Soldaten noch mal
instruiert hat und auf die Veranstaltung
vorbereitet hat
[Musik]
jetzt
also jetzt können wir uns wieder
unterhalten gerade mal richtig laut hier
an dieser
Stelle also Disziplin wird nach wie vor
groß geschrieben muss ja so sein sonst
kann eine Armee irirgendwo auf der Welt
funktionieren
Ehrenformation geht die jetzt noch
weiter wird marschiert sie weiter oder
wird jetzt hier stehen ble bleibt jetzt
hier stehen jetzt kommen die
entsprechenden Kommandos des Führers der
Ehrenformation und dann die Meldung an
den bataillonskommand des
[Musik]
Wachbataillons
achtung hier das
W soung
Auge
Information zum feierlichen göbnis der
soldatinen ges jetzt kommt die Meldung
des Führers der ehinformation an den
Kommandeur des
Wachbataillons
[Musik]
gelöpisastellung augengade
aus das Gewehr
über
Gewehr
ab gelöbes
Aufstellung so die Formationen haben
jetzt hier Stellung bezogen das heißt
das war jetzt der erste Teil der
Einmarsch ist damit beendet was folgt
jetzt als nächstes als nächstes folgt
jetzt die Meldung an den Bundesminister
der Verteidigung Herrn Dr demesier und
danach ist dann das Abschreiten der
Front durch den Bundesminister der
Verteidigung und den Generalinspekteur
der
Bundeswehr das heißt wir haben jetzt die
Gelegenheit noch einmal bisschen zu
sprechen über das was sozusagen 20 Juli
und die Bezüge für diese jungen Menschen
bedeuten kann wie sieht Staatsbürger in
Uniform ist ja immer wieder auch heute
ein wichtiges Stichwort wie werden diese
jungen Leute vorbereitet auf das was sie
später erwartet im Dienst Z Meldung an
den bundesmin wden dadurch vorbereitet
einmal natürlich im Bereich der
politischen Bildung ja was ein
elementarer Bestandteil der Inneren
Führung ist natürlich auch nicht nur in
dem Bereich politische Bildung inere
Führung sonder natürlich auch durch
praktischen Dienst nicht also ich sag
mal Waffenausbildung Sanitätsausbildung
hier Ausbildung am am geschützt am
Panzer das gehört einfach hier mit
[Musik]
dazu das Abschreiten der
gelöbnisaufstellung durch Minister
demier und
generalinspekter Volker
wier die beiden gehen jetzt an allen
vorbei einmal rund um den Platz um den
gesamten Bendlerblock und neben quasi
die Formation die sich aufgestellt hat
ab ganz genau wir werden gleich sehen
sie werden vor der Truppenfahne halten
machen und die Truppenfahne grüßen wir
sehen das
[Musik]
gleich der Minister verneigt sich kurz
und der Generalinspekteur grüßt die
[Musik]
Truppenfahne der Minister der steht ja
im Gegensatz zu seinem Vorgänger für
eine ganz sachliche Art und Weise sein
Ministerium zu führen jedenfalls nach
außenhin merkt man das in der Truppe
auch schlägt sich das in der Truppe
nieder also in der Truppe schlägt sich
das nicht so nieder weil mit dem
Minister haben wir direkt nicht so
fürchterlich viel zu tun ja sondern mit
seinen ein den direkten Vorgesetzen aber
man kann ja ganz offen sagen man merkte
schon dass sein Vorgänger doch mehr in
der Öffentlichkeit zu denen war als er
ist schon ein anderer ein anderer Stil
vorhanden aber das ist ich habe so viel
Minister schon mitgemacht in meiner 35
jährien Dienstzeit es bei jedem Minister
so jeder ist anders und er muss diend
Bundeswehr weiter umbauen
standortsschließungen ist ein wichtiges
Stichwort da wird vieles realisiert
werden müssen bis 2016 wird das große
Veränderung für die Bundeswehr nach sich
ziehen mit Sicherheit wird das große
Veränderung für die Bundeswehr
nachziehen die Reduzierung auf 175 000
Mann im Gegensatz zu 250 000 Mann die
wir mal hatten sind natürlich enorme
Veränderungen die man da im Gefüge der
Bundeswehr haben wird nicht nur
Standortschließung auch
personalveränderung wir sollen ja auch
jünger werden und einsatzbereiter werden
also da sind Veränderungen einfach nicht
auszuschließen das liegt einfach auf der
Hand ja wir sollen auch jünger werden
sagen Sie ein gutes Stichwort die
Freiwilligen die sich jetzt gemeldet
haben wie sieht deren Dienst jetzt
zeitlich aus für wie lange werden sie
Dienst tun und wie geht's dann weiter
das sind so im im Durchschnitt die
freiwillig ferdienstleistenden leisten
im Durchschnitt Dienst von 14 Monaten ja
also man kann von 12 bis 23 Monaten sein
seinen Dienst hier leisten und die
durchschnittliche Zeit ist eben hier 14
Monate die Gäste erheben sich ja der
Minister und der Generalinspekteur
begrüßen die Gäste noch
mal
wir werden gleich hören die Begrüßung
durch den Bundesminister der
Verteidigung Herr Dr
demesier
lisusstellung herzlich begrüße ich unter
uns den Präsidenten des Deutschen
Bundestages Herr Norbert Lammert die
Abgeordneten des Deutschen Bundestages
meine Kollegen und den werrbeauftragten
des Deutschen Bundestages Herrn Helmut
Königshaus den Bundesminister meinen
Kollegen Peter
Ramsauer für die anwesenden Vertreter
des Landes Berlin und aller Länder den
Regierenden Bürgermeister von Berlin
Herrn Klaus Wowereit und den Präsidenten
des Abgeordneten Hauses Herrn Ralf
Wieland ich begrüße Frau Monika von
Hassel und ein meiner Vorgänger
franzosef jung
Exzellenzen Liebe Angehörigen und
Nachkommen des deutschen
Widerstandes liebe
Gäste und vor allem liebe Soldatinnen
und Soldaten
ich begrüße Sie alle hier auf dem
Paradeplatz des Bundesministeriums der
Verteidigung in
Berlin vor dem Ehrenmal für unsere
gefallenen
Kameraden wir gedenken ihrer mit Respekt
und Dankbarkeit wir verneigen uns vor
ihrem Opfer wir bleiben den Angehörigen
verpflichtet
nur wenige Meter entfernt ist auch der
Ort der für den Widerstand gegen das
Nationalsozialisten Regime zentrale
Bedeutung erlangt hat von diesem
Haus damals noch unter der Adresse
bendlerstraße wurde am 20 Juli
1944 der militärische Widerstand gegen
Hitler geführt und im Hof des
Bendlerblocks fand er noch am Abend
desselben Tages sein brutales Ende wir
haben heute daran
erinnert der 20 Juli verpflichtet uns
alle heute und in
Zukunft deshalb sind wir stolz darauf
dass die Adresse des heutigen
Verteidigungsministeriums in Berlin
staufenbergstraße
heißt Liebe Rekruten
sie geloben heute der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland treu zu dienen und das Recht
und die Freiheit des deutschen Volkes
tapfer zu
verteidigen dem eigenen Vaterland treu
dienen aus dieser Motivation handelten
auch die Frauen und Männer des 20 Juli
in der Diktatur legten sie tapfer
Zeugnis ab für das andere Deutschland
ein Deutschland in Freiheit und recht
sie trugen ihren Teil dazu bei dass
Deutschland wieder Teil der
internationalen Gemeinschaft werden
konnte es waren zumeist junge Soldaten
die an diesem Tag den entscheidenden
Schritt zur Tat wagten sie sind ein
bleibendes Vorbild auch für jene die
sich für den Dienst als Soldatin und
soldattin unserer Bundeswehr entschieden
haben und entscheiden und entscheiden
werden also ab heute auch für
Sie die Bundeswehr stellt sich bewusst
in die Tradition des Widerstandes vom 20
Juli 1944 und in die Tradition des
Neubeginns der Bundeswehr mit dem
Staatsbürger in
Uniform Soldatinnen und Soldaten
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter wir
haben als Bundeswehr den Auftrag für die
Sicherheit unseres
Landes den Schutz der BürgerInnen Bürger
und für unsere Interessen einzutreten im
Bündnis und mit internationaler
Verantwortung diesen Auftrag erfüllen
sie als Soldaten und Mitarbeiter der
Bundeswehr Tag für
Tag dafür bin ich Ihnen
dankbar ich weiß dass die
Bundesregierung das Parlament und das
deutsche Volk sich auf sie verlassen
können das erwarte ich auch für die
Zukunft liebe Familien und Freunde der
Rekruten Freiheit und Verantwortung sind
untrennbar miteinander verbunden sie
gehören zusammen darin liegt auch ein
Vermächtnis der Frauen und Männer des 20
Juli für uns und unsere
Zeit dabei scheinen Freiheit und
Verantwortung doch auf den ersten Blick
gar nicht
zusammenzupassen man
vielleicht auch manche junge Menschen
fragen sich bin ich denn frei wenn ich
Verantwortung trage oder werde ich dann
nicht eher
unfrei verpasse ich nicht ein Teil
meiner Freiheit wenn ich einen Dienst
Leiste bin ich anschließend der Dumme
wenn ich meine Zeit und Kraft für andere
für unser Land
einsetze und doch stehen sie heute als
junge Soldaten
hier und treten nach reiflicher
Überlegung und aus freien Stücken den
Dienst in der Bundeswehr
an sie legen Zeugnis ab dass Freiheit
ohne Verantwortung zügellos wird
Freiheit braucht die ordnende Kraft des
Rechts persönliche Freiheit hält nur mit
Verantwortung eine ganze Gesellschaft
dauerhaft frei und
stabil liebe Eltern der jungen
Soldaten sie kommen aus ganz Deutschland
ihre Töchter und Söhne die hier stehen
kommen heute aus Einheiten in
Germersheim Belitz Berlin Bremerhafen
Munster augesdorf holzminten
badfrankenhausen Neubrandenburg und
seed sie haben ihren Töchtern und Söhnen
mit auf den Weg gegeben dass
Selbstverwirklichung auch Einsatz
verlangt sieben haben ihren Töchtern und
Söhnen mit auf den Weg gegeben dass
unsere Freiheit aufmerksam bewahrt und
gelegentlich auch beschützt werden muss
sie haben ihren Töchtern und Söhnen mit
auf den Weg gegeben dass Freiheit eben
immer auch Verantwortung bedeutet sie
haben ihren Töchtern und Söhnen
mitgegeben dass ohne Anstrengung kein
wirklicher Erfolg bevorsteht
sie haben ihren Töchtern und Söhnen
Werte mit auf den Weg gegeben und
vorgelebt was es bedeutet so zu
leben sie haben dazu beigetragen dass
ihre Töchter und Söhne heute hier
stehen dafür sind wir Ihnen als
Gesellschaft bin ich Ihnen ganz
persönlich von Herzen dankbar sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren Soldaten und
Mitarbeiter Rekruten wir sind heute
Bürger in einer freien
wir müssen keinen Widerstand leisten um
unserer Freiheit und unserer
Verantwortung gerecht zu werden als
freie Bürger sind wir aus freien Stücken
und im Interesse der Freiheit gefordert
Verantwortung zu
übernehmen manche in unserer
Nachbarschaft manche in den
Kommunen manche mit einem politischen
Mandat manche im
Ehrenamt und alle sere Soldaten und sie
als Rekruten
übernehmen Verantwortung im Dienst für
die
Bundeswehr und damit für unser Land sie
können stolz sagen wir dienen
Deutschland SPR
verteigungsministeromas imschluss folgt
ein Musikstück da geboten von musikchor
es lautet Marsch 1 Bataillon g von einem
anonymen
Autor
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nun liebe Zuschauer erwarten wir die
gelöbnisansprache durch den
Generalinspekteur der Bundeswehr Volker
wika
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident des
Deutschen
Bundestages
Exzellenzen sehr geehrte Herren
Bundesminister Herr Regierender
Bürgermeister Herr Präsident des
Abgeordneten
Hauses sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
Staatssekretäre sehr verehrte Damen und
Herren Abgeordnete
Eminenzen meine Herren generale und
Admirale sehr verehrte Gäste vor allem
aber Soldatinnen und Soldaten der
Bundeswehr sie liebe Rekruten geloben
heute unserem Land treu zu dienen und
das Recht und die Freiheit des deutschen
Volkes tapfer zu
verteidigen sie tun es
freiwillig sie tun es an einem
bedeutenden Tag der deutschen Geschichte
und an einem bedeutenden Ort für die
Bundeswehr in der sie
dienen wer sich auf diese Weise
persönlich in die Pflicht nimmt unserem
Land und seinen Bürgern zu dienen
handelt mutig sagt unser Bundespräsident
daher ist es mir eine große Genugtuung
dass Ihnen heute so zahlreiche
Repräsentanten aus Politik und
Gesellschaft Kirchen und Kultur
Wirtschaft und Medien ihre Referenz und
ihren Respekt
erweisen sie tun es gemeinsam mit ihren
Angehörigen und Freunden und
verdeutlichen damit in wohltuender Weise
jenen Rückhalt den ihr Handeln in ihrem
persönlichen Umfeld und in der
Gesellschaft
genießt darüber freue ich mich und danke
allen Gästen dass sie uns heute die Ehre
erweisen Liebe Rekruten sie leisten
heute ihr feierliches Gelöbnis an einem
Tag an dem Deutschland an das
gescheiterte Attentat auf Adolf Hitler
vor 68 Jahren erinnert und der mutigen
Frauen und Männer des deutschen
Widerstandes und der Gruppe um Klaus
Schenk Graf von Staufenberg gedenkt
daher könnte auch der heutige Ort ihrer
gelöbnisaufstellung kaum
symbolträchtiger gewählt sein im
vergangenen Jahr haben wir die
gelöbnisfeier vor dem
Reichstagsgebäude dem Sitz des Deutschen
Bundestages begangen jener Ort mit der
Inschrift dem deutschen Volke macht uns
deutlich wem wir
dienen heute sind s sie vor dem Ehrenmal
der Bundeswehr angetreten und schauen
auf die Gedenkstätte Deutscher
Widerstand im
Bendlerblock und hier wird uns in seiner
ganzen Tragweite bewusst was dieses
ausmach für die soldatische Gemeinschaft
aber auch jeden einzelnen von
ihnen die
Bundeskanzlerin sagte ihren älteren
Kameraden zum gleichen Anlass vor 3
Jahren staufenbergs Name steht für eine
gültige Definition der Grenzen des
Gehorsams nämlich dort wo heute unser
Grundgesetz
unveränderliche Grundwerte setzt daraus
erwchst sein Verdienst genau damit
begründen er und seine Weggefährten im
Widerstand eine der wesentlichen
Traditionslinien der Bundeswehr sie sind
uns heute Vorbild Leitbild und
Verpflichtung Zitat
Ende in dieser Verpflichtung auf unsere
Grundwerte Liebe Rekruten macht die
würde als unveräußerliches Recht aller
Menschen auch ihr Gewissen zu einer
moralischen Instanz es anzuleiten und
zur Werteordnung unseres Staates in
Bezug zu setzen ist die wichtigste auf
Gabe der Inneren
Führung denn unser Gewissen folgt keinen
festen Regeln mal schwankend sucht es
nach Ausflüchten und lässt sich
beschwichtigen mal eindringlich wächst
es aus Verunsicherung und sucht nach
Orientierung und mal erschütternd lehmt
es eigenes Handeln oder treibt es
geradezu
an all das ist keine theoretische
gedankenübung meine Lieben Kameradin und
Kameraden sondern vielfach erlebte
Realität einer Armee im
Einsatz einer
Bundeswehr die ihren Soldaten in jungen
Jahren abverlangt was ihren Mitbürgern
ein Leben lang erspart bleibt und das
meint eben auch die Anwendung
militärischer Gewalt in einem
hochkomplexen Regelwerk gegen einen
Gegner der ohne Bindung an das
humanitäre Völkerrecht seine Kräfte so
zur Wirkung bringt dass nur er selbst
Zeitpunkt Ort und Wahl der Mittel
bestimmt sich gerade in solchen Lagen zu
besinnen dass man nicht Soldatin oder
Soldat eines beliebigen Landes ist blet
unser Anspruch und der ist
hoch die jungen Menschen meine den und
Herren die wir einem solchen
Spannungsfeld fernab der Erfahrungswelt
in der deutschen Bevölkerung aussetzen
erwarten zurecht Orientierung und
Führung vor allem aber auch Rückhalt und
Anerkennung und das nimmt uns alle
gemeinsam in die Pflicht wer durch
seinen freiwilligen Dienst in der
Bundeswehr der Gesellschaft aus der er
kommt die Hand ausstreckt darf erwarten
dass sie auch ergriffen wird dazu MT
auch das Ehrenmal der Bundeswehr auf das
wir schauen und mit dem wir all jener
gedenken die in Ausübung des Dienstes
für unser Land ihr Leben verloren er
stünde einem vere
und selbstbewussten Deutschland gut zu
Gesicht wenn wir nicht darum bitten
müssten Liebe Rekruten mit ihnen tritt
erneut ein Jahrgang in die Bundeswehr
ein der auch uns ein querschnittliches
Bild gesellschaftlicher Strömung und
Entwicklungen vermittelt sie kommen aus
allen Teilen unseres Landes und
repräsentieren seine soziale
regionale und kulturelle Vielfalt einige
von ihnen haben ausländische Wurzeln
weil ihre Eltern sich entschlossen
Deutschland zu ihrer neuen Heimat zu
machen darüber freue ich mich denn mit
ihrem Dienst leisten sie ein Bekenntnis
zu unserem Land das weit über den
erwartbaren Rahmen
hinausreicht wer so in der Mitte der
Gesellschaft angekommen ist darf das
auch mit wohlverstandenem
Selbstbewusstsein nach außen vertreten
ich jedenfalls wünsche mir viele
nachaher liebe Kameradin und
Kameraden wenn man Sozialstudien
vergangener Jahre trauen darf sind sie
individualistischer aufgewachsen als
frühere Jahrgänge und pflegen weniger
traditionelle Bindung aber Freundschaft
Verlässlichkeit und Familie sind Ihnen
weiterhin
wichtig durch häufigen Kontakt mit
ausländischen Kulturen eine nahe
grenzenlose Europäische
Union Tourismus und globale Vernetzung
wurden sie viel internationaler groß als
vorangegangene
Generationen die Vielfalt neuer Medien
und deren
Omnipräsenz sind sicher eine
Bereicherung aber sie verführen auch zu
nahe zuu
ununterbrochener
Kommunikation nicht selten beobachten
wir aber auch deren sprachliche und
zwischenmenschliche Verarmung denn
Beziehung zu Mitmenschen werden zunehm
medial gestiftet und auf gleiche Weise
beendet die oft unbequeme
Auseinandersetzung mit dem Gegenüber
bleibt auf der Strecke sie ist aber
wichtig für unsere
Persönlichkeitsbildung denn darin Reifen
wir Beziehungen werden dadurch weniger
belastbar und das spüren wir ihr
Mitteilungsbedürfnis
vervielffach sich über die sozialen
Netzwerke es speist aber auch ein schier
unbegrenztes digitales Gedächtnis das
längst verdrängte Jugendsünden noch nach
Jahren und Jahrzehnten bestrafen kann
die von uns allen zurecht empfundene
Bereicherung berärt also auch Risiken
deren wir uns bewusst sein sollten um
verantwortungsvoll damit umzugehen denn
nun dienen sie in der Bundeswehr und
erfahren dass die Gemeinschaft ein Wert
an sich und das Gebot zur Kameradschaft
verpflichtend ist in ihrer Konsequenz
und Tragweite ist diese Erfahrung
sicherlich so neu für Sie wie Sie es
auch für meine Generation gewesen ist
denn sie bedeutet nicht nur
Rücksichtnahme sondern viel mehr die
Rückstellung eigener Interessen und
Neigungen um nicht ein Gemeinschaft zu
gefährden die in einer Weise aufeinander
angewiesen ist wie man es außerhalb der
Streitkräfte nur selten
antrifft erst daraus nämlich erwächst
dann jene Tapferkeit die in
kameradschaftlicher Einbindung und
ethischer Verpflichtung die Furcht vor
Tod und Verwundung überwinden lässt wer
so handelt hat keinen Grad und wird für
uns alle zum Vorbild mit ihrer mutigen
Entscheidung als Soldat in der
Bundeswehr zu dienen werden Sie erfahren
wie geben ohne zu fordern eine
Gemeinschaft bereichern kann sie werden
aber auch persönlich spüren welche
Genugtuung daraus erwächst denn darin
liegt der Sinn soldatischen Dienens wenn
Sie heute geloben der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland treu zu dienen wir alle die
wir schon in der Bundeswehr
dienstleisten werden ihnen vertrauen
denn nur so dürfen wir von Ihnen
verlangen dass sie bereits in jungen
Jahren große Verantwortung übernehmen
von ihren Vorgesetzten können Sie
erwarten dass sie ihren Führungsanspruch
beweisen indem sie für sie nicht nur nur
Bezugsperson sondern Vorbild sind und
ihrer Verantwortung gerecht werden sie
findet Ausdruck in souveränem Handeln
Entschlossenheit aber auch sicherem
Gespür für die berechtigten Belange
ihrer anvertrauten
Soldaten liebe Kameraden ihre hier
anwesenden Eltern Geschwister und
Freunde kenen sie schon lange Wissen um
ihre Stärken und Schwächen wir kennen
sie noch
nicht für uns sind sie junge Frauen und
Männer die sagen ich bin bereit
Deutschland zu
dienen diese Bereitschaft nimmt uns alle
gemeinsam für sie
ein es sprach der Generalinspekteur der
Bundeswehr Volker wier als nächstes
folgt ein Musikstück mit dem Titel
hochheidexsburg von Rudolf
[Musik]
Herzer
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ein konzertanter fast schon beschwingter
Marsch hat
oberstis gerade gesagt das ändert aber
nichts daran dass es ein aufregender
Moment ist für die jungen Leute denn
drei sind schon umgekippt bzw führ
werden das anstrengender Moment auch ja
kann passieren wir ja vorhin schon
drüber gesprochen die Soldatin und
Soldaten sind erst seit ja ca D Wochen
im Dienst die Hektik die man heute
gehabt hat dann trinkt man
möglicherweise hier wenig und dann kann
das natürlich schon mal passieren
wünschen wir Ihen von dieser Stelle hier
gute Besserung und dass sie gleich
wieder hier mitmachen K ja einige sahen
blass aus aber so schlimm war es glaube
ich nicht jetzt steuern wir auf den
Höhepunkt so langsam aber sicher zu auf
das Gelöbnis das ist jetzt aber glaube
ich noch das vortreten der fahenabordung
vortreten der fahenabordnung und hier
natürlich auch eine Besonderheit ich
hatte ja schon am Anfang angesprochen
dass wir zehn Einheiten hier haben jede
Einheit hat eine Truppenfahne das W
natürlich heute bchen viel dass wir zehn
truppenfahen hier hätten also hat man
sich entschieden wir nehmen die
Truppenfahne von
[Musik]
Wachbataillon ich
genau die Truppenfahne ist
jetzt vorgetreten fahnträger ist immer
ein Unteroffizier mit porte P begleitet
von zwei
Offizieren
[Applaus]
stellung Abordnung der Rekruten
vortreten jetzt tritt die
rekrutenabordnung vor wir sehen es sind
sechs Soldatin und Soldaten
her Luftwaffe und Marine werden hier
repräsentiert und sie werden jetzt gich
da
vorne ihre Hände auf die Truppenfahne
legen und dann das Gelöbnis
stellvertreten für alle dort vorne
ablehen
[Musik]
gelöbnisaufstellung zum feierlichen
Gelöbnis das Gewehr
Achtung präsentiert
das Z Truppenfahne Augen rechts
Soldatin und Soldaten sprechen sie mir
nun zum feierlichen Gelöbnis
nach ich gelobe ich gelobe der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland treu zu
dienen treu zu
dienen und das Recht und das Recht und
die Freiheit des deutschen Volkes und
die
freiites tapfer zu verteidigen tapfer zu
[Applaus]
verteidigen das war also der Moment des
Gelöbnisses am 68
jahrestag des 20 Juli 1944 des Versuches
durch Staufenberg und seine
Mitstreiter adalf Hitler zu töten und
damit dem NS-Staat ein Ende zu bereiten
es folgt die
[Applaus]
Nationalhymne
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das Gewehr
ü Gewehr
ab gelöbnes
[Musik]
auffstellung
Soldatin und Soldaten ich stelle fest
dass sie gelobt haben der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland treu zu dienen und bereit
sind das Recht und die Freiheit des
deutschen Volkes tapfer zu
verteidigen nun folgt das
Bekenntnis das des Treue beekenntnisses
durch also die Bekräftigung durch G
Minister auch noch durch Volker wi den
Generalinspekteur durch den ich se dort
auch den Präsidenten des Bundestages
Herr Dr Lammert ja und durch den
Kommandeur des
Wachbataillons sie haben gelobt
Deutschland treu zu dienen und das Recht
und die Freiheit des deutschen tapf zu
verteidigen das meint auch das
demonstrationrecht in diesem Land ich
sag das deshalb denn von Ferne hört man
Protest piffe aufgicht
selbstverständlich das das gehört mit
dazu sage ich mal dass man auch dafür
entsprechend hier eintritt und da dieses
Recht verteidigt was ja auch ein hohes
Gut ist wie lange haben sie sich
verpflichtet Monate Monate welchem
Schulabschluss Abitur schön gut viel
Erfolg danke
schön herzlich Glückwunsch alles Gute wo
kommen sie her Kassel Kassel Sanität
jawohl genau hier zu erkennen ne wie
viel Monate 12 und vielleicht noch
länger oder war es das jawohl danach
wollte ich studieren bei der Bundeswehr
Medizin jawohl was haben sie für
NC
1,8 nicht schlecht hatte ich auch alles
Gute ja
danke ja auch Ihnen herzlich willkommen
Herz Glückwunsch alles Gute und vielen
Dank danke wo stamen sie her aus großen
ehich wo lieg denn das in Thüringen mhm
schön wie lange haben sie sich
verpflichtet für 23 Monate warum nicht
zwei JRE 23 Monate war das maximale was
man gut Zeitsoldat vielleicht das kommt
danach bei bewrungise alles Gute danke
schön war hart
formalausbildung ist gut machbar Glück
hab dass der Sommer nicht so heiß war ne
oh
ja auch ihen her Glückwunsch alles Gute
viel dan heißen
sie okay sie stammen woher aus na ja das
gehört dann ja dazu haben sie Soldaten
in der Familie ja Vater ne der Onkel der
Onkel gen und der hat zugeraten ihr
Onkel hat Zug geraten ja gut wie viel
Monate machen sie
12 alles Gute vielen
Dank Herz glü dank vielen Dank dass Sie
dabei sind ja danke und viel Erfolg wo
stammen sie her Freiburg freisgau jawohl
aus im Süden und jetzt
in germersim die Grundausbildung genau
korrekt war hart bitte war hart bisher
formaldien war in Ordnung die
Grundausbildung beginnt jetzt schauen
wir mal wie es weiter geht mussen viel
formalausbildung sie hier gerade
Auslaufen könen genau war auch ein
hartes Stück ja aber es war nicht so
heiß wie viel haben sie sich
verpflichtet 23 Monate und danach möchte
ich gerne SHZ werden Offizier
militärfachlichen Dienst Richtung
Flugsicherung haben sie Abitur nee
mittlere Reife holen sie jetzt nach
jawoh viel Erfolg alles Gute danke
schön also der erfährt man doch einiges
jungen Rekruten bei diesen Fragen vom
Minister stellvertretend für all die
anderen hat er Hal kurz interterview her
geführt und damit klingt die
Veranstaltung schon so langsam aus
gleich gibt's noch die Hymne das ist
schön zunächst die Nationalhymne und
dann die Europahymne ja das ist ja
beziehungsreich gerade in diesen Tagen
wo es um Eurorettung und ähnliches geht
hat ja nicht nur mit der Eurorettung zu
tun es ist auch so ein bisschen von der
Geschichte von der ich vorhin erzählt
habe dass wir hier auch anlässlich des
20 JuLis internationale Gäste gehabt
haben wie beispielsweise den
polnischen Staatspräsidenten den
holländischen Ministerpräsidenten den
norwegischen Ministerpräsidenten und da
ist das so eingeführt worden und da ist
das also quasi so mit in den hier in
diese Veranstaltung mit aufgenommen
worden ist auch so
geblieben also die Rekruten gehen jetzt
zurück in ihre rein ihre
Kameraden dann die europahemde ich habe
es erwähnt es gibt einige Proteste hier
in der nee aber es sind viel viel
weniger als in den Jahren zuvor ist es
auch ein Zeichen dass die Bundeswehr
jetzt mitten in der Gesellschaft
angekommen ist mehr als früher
vielleicht also ich sage mal die bundesr
ist schon immer mitten in der
Gesellschaft angekommen ich bin 35 Jahre
dabei fahre auch ab und zu hierstellung
in Uniform zum Dienst wie der U-Bahn hab
da noch nie irgendwelche Probleme hier
na ja sie war aber mal mehr in der
Kritik als heute ja das ist
vielleicht auch immer eine eine eine
Frage der Zeit wenn Sie beispielsweise
hier die nachrüstungsdiskussion aus den
80er Jahren ansprechen da ging es
einentsprechend hier emotionaler
emotionaler
zu ich glaube ist einfach in der
Gesellschaft angekommen ist ein fester
Bestandteil dieser
Gesellschaft
rechts
Fahne
Marsch kommt
ja so so schnell geht's nicht die
Veranstaltung zuende die Truppenfahne
tritt jetzt wieder zurück in die
Ehrenformation und danach hören wir dann
noch
hier ein entsprechendes Musikstück die
EUR die europahimne hier und dann
Ausmarsch und dann ist die Veranstaltung
nachher auch zu
[Musik]
Ende
Augen gerade
aus
[Musik]
das Gewehr
über zum Ausmarsch der Truppenfahne
Augen
rechts
informformation damit beginnt jetzt der
Schlussteil des Gelöbnisses an diesem 20
Juli nämlich der Ausmarsch der
Ehrenformation 400 rekuten haben ihr
Gelöbnis abgelegt Herr oberstlutn zisack
was folgt nun für diese jungen Menschen
wie geht jetzt weiter mus mal guck wir
haben hier schon die
unterschiedlichsten heute abend
beispielsweise W die m nach Hause fahren
und danach geht die Grundausbildung der
Soldaten natürlich weiter nicht mit dem
Schwerpunkt formalausbildung sondern die
Ausbildungsabschnitte die wir vorhin
schon angesprochen haben
Sanitätsausbildung
waffenausbildungusbildung das ist dann
schwer ja was die Zukunft diesen jungen
Menschen bringen wird das wissen wir
nicht möglicherweise wird der eine oder
andere vielleicht abspringen werden und
ein anderen beruflichen Weg einschlagen
aber das zeigen ja die ersten
Erfahrungen doch ein Großteil bleibt
dabei bei der Bundeswehr und findet dort
seinen Weg seine berufliche Zukunft wir
wollen ihnen Glück wünschen von Herzen
Glück wünschen dass sie all das finden
werden was Sie suchen mögen und dass sie
das Gelöbnis was sie heute abgelegt
haben ja vielleicht auch ein ganz klein
wenig im Sinne von Staufenberg in die
Zukunft mit hinüber nehmen werden das
war's aus dem
Verteidigungsministerium live aus dem
Bendlerblock einem beziehungsreichen
historischen Ort Oberleutnant uwe
ziesack und ich wir sagen vielen Dank
für die Aufmerksamkeit liebe Zuschauer
und wir entlassen
sie Ramsauer und die anderen
Ehrengäste mit einer Zusammenstellung
mit einem Zusammenschnitt einiger
Musikstücke bis zur Tagesschau einiger
Musikstücke die hier auch im Vorprogramm
zum Vortrage gekommen sind und fangen an
mit einem Musikstück mit dem Titel frei
weg damit sagen wir tschüss hier aus
Berlin ja bleiben Sie bitte weiter bei
Phönix denn es lohnt sich immer auf
Wiedersehen
so Meldung an den Bundesminister
derteigung Augen
rechts Minister ich melde das Ende des
feierlichen
[Musik]
gelücknisses
aus kuten Kompanen
runter Einheitsführer
übernehmen
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
verhrte Gäste das feierliche
[Musik]
gü
[Applaus]
[Musik]